Một số thông bàn người phân môn bộ chính quy trung ơn Khaddam Anna Adi Ria,
Quay Rhan, ông Ebrahim, John Fagari, Chúc biết,
Tây Rhan đã không hương hai nghìn này bài thông người lái và hơn 6 châm tên lua.
Nhằm và các mục tiêu quay Serao bỏ ní trên tình thần này,
Kêu ông Joe Fagari, các đo tấn công được chiến thái với các đo ổn định,
Bộ nhiều khu vực tại Serao phải dưới chi tiền trạm báo động,
và người dân phải chua, trong hậm chứng bỏng trong hàm một chăm dở.
Ông cũng Joe sẵn lực lượng Israel đã bố chỉ các khí tại quân sự,
gần khu vực dân cư, sống Iran bắn thích được sống định và tấn công của mục tiêu chính xác,
mà tây Iran cho là liên quan đến hỏng đặc quân sự.
Hoàn chú giải raam cho biết,
hài của nước này đã nhá mục tiêu với lực lượng Mỹ tại một trạc quân sự ước củawan,
chung khi lực lượng màn đất tế này, tấn công mà mấy bài thông người lái,
báo chủ sở quân sự của Mỹ tại Oby,
Thổ khu vực có đi s tân quay Iraq.
Một gia Iran cũng tuyên bố đã sự giúp bài thông người lái,
nhằm vào tổn bài U.S. này sẽ hibera hem linh cân,
của một số khu sở quân sự quay sở.
Chúng khi đó, lực lượng phòng ve sở quay sở biết đã tìm hành được tấn công thứ 18,
nhằm vào tây Iran nhá mất cơ sở hạ tần Mỹ sở lã linh quan đến nâng lực quân sự quay
Iran. Dởi chú giải raam cũng khẳng định nước này đã chuẩn bị cho khả năng xung đội kéo dài.
Bà đang phát triển thêm các loại bố khi mới có thể được triển 2,
chúng ta sẽ đoạn tiếp theo của chiến dịch.
Về phần mạnh chương mục của phòng bắn quay trái,
tâm thông đứa nương trông khẳng định,
tôi không đặt dưới ăn thời gian trở bất cứ điều gì,
tôi muốn sải có xong việc này.
Chuy đó, ông cũng từng dựa đoạn có cuộc không kích của Mỹ và Iran nhằm vào Iran,
có thể kéo sải khoảng 4.5 tuần.